ironically in our culture in our
inverted culture the words oppression
and the words privilege
now mean the opposite they've been
reversed so the ability to claim
oppression actually carries with it
certain social privileges for instance
if these screaming children in here
weren't able to claim some false sense
of privilege they would not only have
been ejected from the lecture hall a
long time ago
they would have been expelled from the
university they should have been
expelled from 10th grade
but because they can claim certain
social advantages
by ways of a false oppression they are
allowed to sit here
and degrade the american university a
privilege ironically is a special right
and today because oppression carries
social privileges
a privilege is actually a disadvantage
if you are deemed to have privilege
you are told to shut up usually by
heckling crowds
you are told to check your privilege
you are told that your opinion is
invalid you are told that you do not
have the right to speak
you are told that your very identity is
wicked
that you are guilty of some great crime
i'll let them exhaust themselves for a
second
and so all social pressure incentivizes
people to claim oppression
and victimhood and to deny their own
privileges
this creates ever multiplying victim
groups false victim groups like these
people
this creates ever multiplying racial
victims sec
i know you're so oppressed my dears i
know life is so hard for you
you have to live in the richest most
equitable most just country in the
history of the world
you have to get a college education you
have to voluntarily go to lectures it's
so awful
i can't imagine that you know the people
people who are in war-torn nations they
must truly
they must truly pity you good-bye
goodbye then
[Applause]
i i'm not that thank you gentlemen i
appreciate your support but i'm not that
intimidated by these guys
[Applause]
you know there's a course being taught
right now
at an american university on angry white
men
and i when i look at who's angry i'm not
so
sure i i know i seem so hateful
you guys seem lovely and sweet you guys
seem so compassionate and lovely
but uh you hope that what
well it's very difficult to use my
platform when people use the heckler's
veto to try to shut up
any opinion that disagrees
i didn't think i was this intimidating i
believe that gentleman just threw paint
[Music]
[Applause]
on
i think someone someone threw milk on me
or something i don't really know
that's what happens when you assault
people by the way folks
that's what happens
[Music]
[Applause]
i got some sort of paint all over my
speech
[Applause]
thanks maybe you'll be able to hear it
online you know
hopefully over the dinner
[Music]
[Music]
they did that because that gentleman
threw a bunch of some unknown substance
on